Time travel, finger guns, and buzzing
electricity. No, "Better Call Saul" didn't
become a science fiction series in its finale.
But it did give longtime fans plenty to ponder.
At the start of Season 6, a worn
paperback copy of H.G. Wells' "The
Time Machine" is confiscated from
Saul Goodman's abandoned mansion;
it's only fitting that in the series finale, both
that book and the notion of time travel return in
flashbacks to key moments with Mike Ehrmantraut,
Walter White, and Jimmy's brother Chuck.
While on their desert trek with
Lalo's money from Season 5's "Bagman,"
Jimmy asks Mike what he would
do if he had a time machine.
He poses the same question to Walt while
they await getting disappeared by Ed the
vacuum cleaner repairman during the events of
the "Breaking Bad" episode "Granite State."
Mike, unsurprisingly, thinks of his doomed son
Matty and the first time he ever took a bribe.
Walt, however, scoffs at the
very idea of time travel, saying:
"You are talking about regret. So if you want
to ask about regrets, just ask about regrets."
Jimmy gives Mike and Walt shallow
answers to his own question.
But the real answer seemingly comes in the
third flashback as Jimmy stocks groceries
for his brother. Jimmy and Chuck's
relationship was always contentious,
with Jimmy often straining for Chuck's approval
and love while not quite getting it. This time,
it's Chuck who makes an effort to
reach out, and Jimmy who refuses it.
"There's no shame in going
back and changing your path."
"When have you ever changed your path?"
He leaves Chuck alone to read "The
Time Machine" by lantern light.
If Jimmy had accepted that small olive branch,
who knows how things might have turned out.
Wayfarer Airlines flight 515 is an important
part of the "Breaking Bad" mythology. The plane's
fate was a symbol of the way Walter White's
actions had terrible, unexpected consequences.
His decision to let Jesse's girlfriend Jane die
leads to her father, an air traffic controller,
inadvertently causing a midair collision
that rains down debris over Albuquerque.
Stylistically, the event coined many
of the elements that "Breaking Bad"
and "Better Call Saul" would be known
for, with evocative black-and-white
prologues flashing forward to the disaster and
a secret message hidden in the episode titles.
The Wayfarer disaster was also something that
Saul Goodman milked for all it was worth,
wearing a memorial ribbon on his lapel
for the remainder of "Breaking Bad."
In the "Better Call Saul" finale, he is extradited
back to New Mexico to stand trial for his many
crimes, flying with a U.S. Marshal aboard a
Wayfarer flight. Later, he enters the courtroom
resplendent in a shiny Saul Goodman suit, complete
with a Wayfarer ribbon pinned to the lapel.
The ghost of Chuck hangs
heavy over the series finale.
Saul's final courtroom performance has
two major callbacks to his late brother.
The most explicit comes as Saul torpedoes
his plea deal by admitting that he was
not Walter White's unwitting victim, but a
willing participant in his criminal empire.
"That night, I saw opportunity.
A shot at big money."
Saul soon finds himself talking about Chuck,
and the shot cuts to an angle high
above the courtroom behind an exit sign
buzzing with electricity. That image is a reminder
of Season 3's "Chicanery," in which Jimmy proves
that Chuck's professed electromagnetic
sensitivity was a psychological condition.
The meat of Saul's speech, in which he turns
away from a self-serving lie and faces the truth,
calls to mind Jimmy's testimony to the
Bar Association at the end of Season 4.
There, he tearfully invoked the name of
his brother as nothing more than a con to
get reinstated as a lawyer, making a fool
of everyone listening, including Kim. His
final performance reverses that. He praises
Chuck's brilliant legal mind, acknowledges
his culpability in the events that led to
Chuck's suicide, and reclaims his family name.
"The name's McGill. I'm James McGill."
It is all sincere, and it is all for Kim.
Jimmy's plan all along was not to get himself
off the hook, but to redeem himself in her eyes.
Jimmy's seven-year plea deal at a cushy federal
prison with a golf program goes up in smoke,
replaced by an 86-year sentence in a
maximum-security federal prison. But things
could be worse. He finds himself working in the
prison cafeteria, putting his Cinnabon skills to
work baking bread. His long tenure as Saul Goodman
has earned him the respect of his fellow inmates
and guards alike, who all refer to him by his
famous alias. And thanks to an unexpected visitor,
he gets to be Jimmy McGill once again, if only
for the length of one smoke. Kim shows up,
posing as his lawyer thanks to her New Mexico Bar
Association I.D., which never expired. The two
of them share a cigarette in near silence, just
like they did in their very first scene together.
As Kim leaves, likely for the last time, Jimmy
watches from the prison yard and gives her the
same finger guns that ended Season 4 and
introduced the legal world to Saul Goodman.
The same finger guns Kim gave at the end of Season
5 as she devised a plan to ruin Howard Hamlin. But
while both of those gestures signified the
start of something, this one is a goodbye.